in Delirious when that woman yelled out  you just hear shut up [ __ ] that's  that's Charlie  and that's why Eddie laughed so you knew  that right oh I didn't know that so  during delirious and that's why Eddie  just laughed and actually during the  taping it's on the special a woman  yelled something I like and and  instantaneous year shut up [ __ ] and it  was Charlie and Eddie [ __ ] just  dropped the mic and started walking  around because he was so protective of  him sweating and [ __ ]  [Music]  yo they know I was a ventriloquist too  well Charlie told me stories about doing  Security on his tour and was saying yeah  my brother had to let me go because I  got too aggressive but he used to say  they said yeah man if we're walking down  the street and somebody yo you ain't  funny he goes I go and [ __ ] him up  he's like yeah  you're [ __ ] talking about my brother  like that